[Music]
here guys in this video I'm bringing you
a popular season a Pollock that was
posted on Game of Thrones subreddit by
Russian translators this Lake is
allegedly coming from a guy who works at
a media a company who is in charge of
official Russian translation for all HBO
TV shows including Game of Thrones I got
to say that many things in this alleged
pot leaked even if said and better does
seem reasonable and most of it I can
actually see happening in the final
season however if you don't want to be
potentially spoiled it's time for you to
close this video okay here's the alleged
plot leaked we'll be reading it and
discussing it along the way the guys
sharing it is Russian and he apologizes
for a few misspelled names and words in
general he says hi folks I have been
inspired by spoilers for the last three
years with my friends are on Russian
spoilers community at vk.com it's a
Russian Facebook this year I found a guy
who claims he as a friend at a media
it's a corporation who is in charge of
official Russian translation for HBO TV
shows he shared a pack of spoilers
recently actually I'm not confident in
this guy but I want to share this video
he'll ready predict the trailer release
date after some random guys from free
fall to be honest sorry about possible
grammar mistakes English is not my
native also I put my comments in
brackets let's get it started with
Winnefeld battle is going to be present
in the third episode snap Chevy the
horse legs from the trailer ending scene
from the second episode the battle
winner fell in Episode three is a long
known fact going into season 8 and this
final shot for the trailer in which we
have the unsullied in the Knights of the
Vale de Brienne Podrick and Jorah
waiting for the knight king's army to
attack with the knight king's army
showing up is definitely either from
episode 2 ending scene or the episode 2
reopening scene as the plot league says
it's one of those shots that will happen
just before the battle starts but
somehow by the look of it I still say
it's from episode 2 ending scene but it
could still definitely be from episode 3
opening scene next it says goes to be
killed in the third episode now I don't
know about that but goes we'll
definitely fight alongside Jon Snow in
the battle for venom fell against the
night king and his army if you look
closely on the official trailer you
could even know this ghost in the back
and in case you missed it pay attention
to the left of juror moment when the
camera pans on his hardened battle-ready
face and you'll notice something that is
out of focus something white and durable
shaved moving around in the background
it's definitely ghost in my opinion and
there somewhere is Jon Snow as well it
has been confirmed that goes to finally
return in season eight and I can only
say finally we have not seen ghost ever
since Jon's resurrection probably
wondering where ghost even is his MN FL
the shorteners confirmed that ghost a
damn Winterfell with Sansa but Jon left
to meet any dragon stop matter-of-fact
ghost was supposed to be in one scene of
the previous season when discussing his
episode Stormborn on a season 7 blu-ray
commentary track writer cogman revealed
that he wrote the scene featuring ghost
but it got cut out we were supposed to
see ghost and shall emerge from
Winterfell crypts right after he
threatened Littlefinger but before he
bade goodbye to Sansa so summer in their
ghost was supposed to finally reappear
cogman provided some more details there
was a bit here where Jon came out to the
Crypt and ghost came up to him and he
petted him and said take care of Sansa
watch over her for me but I guess those
dire wolves are expensive I guess a good
cut
instead of goes the showrunner decided
to fulfill their long waited wish of
having an undead bear anyways the
production has much higher budget for
Season eight and we had said it only
makes sense for girls to finally
reappear
Jamil reigneth with ghost early on in
season and I'm sure we'll see more of
him in the following episodes especially
in the battle for Winterfell that is
taking place in episode 3 let's go this
league plot is fake and ghost lives many
years with his sister named area next it
says Tyrion Lannister will betray John
and Danny but not because of Cersei
King's Landing will be destroyed by the
Wildfire which is long known spoiler
from freaky doctor venom felt will be
burned down in the battle which is also
known from leaks at photos the sixth
episode is going to be named the dream
of spring
identically with the seventh book the
clip from Tyrion from the trailer is him
on his own trial one of the Dragons
still passed the sentence Tyrion
betraying Dany burning King's Landing
with wildfire and this shattering
official trailer being from his trial is
all I've already discussed in my recent
video in short King's Landing will be
burned down in episode 5 that is
confirmed by leaked photos and
- most likely batarians doing for which
he will be judged and burned by Jorgen
this exact thing was licked by freaky
doctor the most reliable spoilers source
in his community he already spoiled
season six and seven and even season a
trailer date length and its content so
this season eight leak will likely come
true as well wherever like it or not the
fall of NFL is also confirmed by the
leaked photos and now this [ __ ] says
is that massage will be part of the
fight for VIN FL which he most
definitely will better Davos likes it or
not and white Walker or denied king
himself will try to resurrect ghost the
night king resurrecting ghost might have
even been hinted by an actor who plays
the night King verdict said and at the
same time spoiled another stare down
between just lament the night king that
is set to take place in season eight
thinking back to hardhome he teases
there's also the moment when Jon Snow
was on the boat and the night King
looked at him and raised his arms
there's a similar and even stronger
moment between Jon and the night king
this time perhaps the night King truly
kills and resurrects ghosts at the
veining another battle against Jon Snow
and the old Jon can do is look just like
back at hardhome
but still the slick part is far from
being confirmed legit so let's hope for
the best then it says that Joshua
parentage will be revealed to John in
the end of episode 1 he won't believe it
but brain will describe his ship beyond
the wall like he was there also brain
will say you know nothing Jon Snow he
also describes a scene from episode 2
that will take place in the crypts of
NFL and it will be about John and Danny
talking about Ned and his promise to Jon
to talk about his mother the next time
they see each other which unfortunately
never happened
the scene was actually leaked a few
months ago and confirmed by the official
trailer next it says the most epic scene
will be in episode 3 during battle of
NFL the joke on this area will fight in
the sky of the battle rages beneath them
and valve Winterfell burns in episode 5
it will allegedly witness called game
ball during the Battle of King's Landing
huge King's Landing battle in episode 5
is a confirmed thing well the score game
ball is definitely something I can see
happening and have been expecting to
happen even an actor who plays the Hound
hinted that this confrontation with his
brother a few days ago by saying there
will be a chance of squaring up to his
brother and facing those demons the game
ball is definitely going down then it
says that the final episode will be
something like talking about
and similar to the 10th episode of
season 3 after the red wedding legit or
not link plot is definitely not wrong
about this one as well
episode 3 and 5 will see all major
battles with the last one being a battle
for King's Landing and an episode 6 will
be about the spring that comes after the
long night at some point of the season
Danny will apparently teach John have to
ride the dragon and his dragon will be
raiga this is something I have been
talking about so many times on this
channel
and John you'll almost certainly ride a
dragon named that our Father the most
surprising part of this alleged leak
plot is this it's a Jaime will not
reveal Circe's betrayal to others maybe
there's a mistake in translation but I
can't see Jaime not revealing sources
betrayal to Starks and Danny after all
in the official trailer he says I
promise to fight for living and I intend
to keep that promise a line which likely
comes after Jaime revealed that Cersei
is not coming with her army and after
day in your sense I'm wondering why
would they believe him and his sister is
clearly not going to help them next it
says the golden company will fight
against the unsullied and the golden
company will then it doesn't save
anywhere Rhaegar will apparently die
nips owed five during the battle for
King's Landing which I can see happening
back to episode one it says that one of
the first scenes to beat the night Kings
armies Aryan tag in some places near the
wall this is actually something many of
us predicted about the final season the
night King is in far north and between
the wall and Vener Felder's many castles
on his way the night king will arrive at
Winterfell in episode 3 when we'll have
this huge battle but in the meantime he
will destroy all the castles on his way
the next point in this league plot is
very interesting it says the night Kings
goal is bran Stark the nutria Draven and
his time traveling was reason to create
White Walkers now here's why this is so
interesting to me and even leading me to
believe there's some possibility of this
entire league plot being true and I read
this yesterday I read it I firstly
thought to myself this is fake and
probably written by a fan who watched
the trailer and read an Entertainment
Weekly interview with the night king
that came out just the other day in that
interview an actor who plays the night
King said that the night King has a
special person and target he wants to
kill and a person is the only reason of
his march south and we'll find out who
that person is in the final season
however even though dispos'd did
resurface just yesterday and reddit is
just a translation and the original
posts written on
was actually published a bit before this
sinner will be the night king that's
what this plot point is particularly
interesting to me and even makes me
think that this might actually be legit
season a plot leaked back to it next it
says that John Danny Arya the hound and
since a particular Will Survive Episode
five battle Cersei will lose her child
and the scene from the trailer where
Cersei has tears in eyes and drinks wine
is not her morning her unborn baby but
actually her after she hears the news
about Winterfell battle the nuttiest
pretty much destroyed Winterfell and
killed most people and since Jaime was
there as well Cersei things Jamie's dead
it also says that Theon will fight you
on in one-on-one fight the winner of
that fight is not mentioned then it says
it will see one flashback from Robert's
rebellion and it will happen right from
the capital Falls
once again legit or not leaked plot is
definitely not wrong about this one
either
George are Martin said himself we learn
all we need to know about Robert's
abelian in Season eight which is why
there will not be Roberts Abilene
prequel show which pretty much confirms
there will be at least one born through
Robert's rebellion flashback scene also
Jon Snow will apparently very plate mail
with both stark in Targaryen sigils in
Episode five and six which would mean
Jon Snow survives game thrones or least
survives until the final episode it says
there will be three sides in Episode
five battle that will follow Targaryen
slain Easter's and the knight king in
his army and finally it says there's 90%
chance that there will not be a second
trailer that's an interesting and pretty
bold statement especially since HBO
praises have the first season a trailer
broke all records and even more so
because this trailer will detract even
more attention to the final season hence
making them even more money and
therefore them not releasing it would
not make much sense but we'll see
they're hip guys allegedly plot of the
final season I'll leave the links of the
original post which are shared on vkd--
the Russian biggest social media and a
translated version that was posted on
reddit in description down below please
let me know your opinion about this do
you think it's legit
do you think it's fake do you like some
of these points make sure to let me know
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace